هذه مدرسه لولوى عبد الوهاب القطامي التي
قصفت بفعل قوات الاحتلال بعد ان تواجدت
بها العائلات النازحه فرارا من القصف
وخوفا من القصف الاسرائيلي على اعتبار ان
هذه المدارس امنه لكن قوات الاحتلال قصفت
هذه المدرسه بعدد من القذائف بشكل مباشر
مما ادى الى استشهاد عدد من افراد
العائلات النازحه داخل هذه المدرسه هذا هو
احد الصفوف التي قصف بداخله المواطنون
وادى الى استشهاد ما يقارب ست عشره
فلسطينيا داخل هذا المكان تلجا العائلات
الى المدارس اللي على اعتبار انها امنه
وقوات الاحتلال لن تقصف هذه المدارس لكن
هذه المدارس قصفت بشكل متكرر من قوات
الاحتلال اولادي كانوا في الصف امنين
قاعدين واولادي اولادي كمان معهم وكنت
معهم ومرت ابني معهم وبنتي معهم واولادها
معها ف حدفوا علينا قضيه
يفه وقذفه كمان ثنوا القذيفه الاولى خربت
الثانيه دمرت مرقت على اودي على ابني وعلى
اولاده وقتلوه وانقتل وكل هتهم شهداء ان
شاء الله كل العيله كل العيله ان مسحت مسح
ما ظل ولا واحد طيب وانا دفنتهم بدي كل
هيته ال 15 نفر هذه اثار احدى القذائف
التي سقطت على الجالسين داخل هذه المدرسه
ايضا لم تسلم ال العائلات وهي داخل اماكن
النزوح من القصف الاسرائيلي اجانا
بالدبابه هي طبق قصف قصف عشوائي تفاجانا
في اولاد اخوي استشهدوا ومرا اخوي استشهدت
ايش السبب مش فاهمين عند ثلاث انا اخويا
مره اخويا ولاد اخويا الاثنين اجانا في
النصيبه هذه كارثه مش نصيبه يعني صف امنين
قاعدين اطفال زي ما انت شايف هذا المكان
اطفال لا معهم سلاح ولا معهم ح ولا معهم
اي حاجه ما اجانا الا الداف في المدرسه ه
بسبب مين فيش مقاومه وبيجي ققولك نستهدف
المقاومه فيش مقاومه اصال
مقاومه هذا
هو الصف كما يسمى الذي ياوي النازحين
عائله كامله في هذا المكان هذه اثار
الدماء قصفت هذه العائله هي داخل الصف
كانت هنا العائله جالسه
بامان لا تنفذ اي اعمال لكن كانت تتجهز
لتناول طعام الغذاء هذه العائله الان كلها
دفنت عائله المصري من عائله المصري طبعا
دفنت هذه هي اثار النازحين في هذا المكان
هي هذه اثار عائله النازحه هذه جالونات
المياه التي تصطف العائلات ساعات طويله
لتعبئتها
يعني بديل الكهرباء اللد الكهربائي
وبطاريات الكهرباء كل هذه الممتلكات تدل
على ان هذه العائله نازحه شيا قوات
الاحتلال التي سق قذيفه قوات الاحتلال
التي سقطت اثارها في مكان قتلت هذه
العائله بشكل مباشر جدا تهجرنا لعده مراحل
من مدرسه لمدرسه يطلعونا يقول روح المنطقه
ح وهذه منطقه امن هذه المنطقه امن غرب غزه
بنموت فيها شهيد في مدرسه يعني هذه الامور
ما صرت
فحنا كمان بنوجه الرساله للاحتلال انه
احنا ممدين على هذه الارض بنطلع حتى لو
متنا لازم نظل نظل في المدرسه ونظل في
المنطقه ما بنطلع ما بنتجر على الجنوب
احنا بلادنا بل الشمال ولازم نرجع على
الشمال وعت
حنون لا جت العائلات الى هذه المدرسه على
اعتبار انها امنه وبتوجيهات من قوات
الاحتلال لكن يستمر الجيش الاسرائيلي بقصف
العائلات المدنيه داخل اماكن النزوح
اسماعيل الغول قناه الجزيره مدينه غزه